en direct dans ce gîte et christophe
prudhomme médecin au samu de
seine-saint-denis porte parole de
l'association des médecins urgentistes
de france et responsable cgt bonjour
christian prudhomme 4000 arrêt de
travail à 21 morts chez les médecins
libéraux votre réaction comment est ce
qu'on aurait pu éviter un tel drame
écoutez en pouvant disposer de moyens de
protection adaptée dès le début de la
crise qui n'a pas été le cas puisque
vous allez parler de la polémique sur
les masques il est clair que la gestion
de la crise par le gouvernement est
catastrophique
effectivement nous a menti y compris des
experts ont raconté n'importe quoi parce
que les mesures préconisées n'était
absolument pas motivée par des arguments
valides et de santé publique mais
uniquement par la pénurie de moyens une
urine masque pénurie de blues est donc
aujourd'hui y compris pour les
personnels hospitaliers
on voit fleurir des tutoriels pour
pouvoir fabriquer les blues à partir de
sacs poubelles vous voyez bien que c'est
une situation catastrophique et on voit
bien que nous sommes très inquiets nous
les personnels de santé les médecins
parce que visiblement le même flux
continu continu pour le déconfinement
vous savez que en termes de santé
publique
si on veut que les mesures préconisées
soit appliquée il faut qu il ya une
confiance de la population pour qu'elle
accepte de mettre en oeuvre ces mesures
quand il ya la perte de confiance
qu'elle qu'à l'heure actuelle et bien on
risque le client christophe prudhomme
vous avez dit on nous a menti
est ce que vous allez intenter des
actions contre le gouvernement si oui
lesquels on sait par exemple que le
collectif de soignant ses dix neuf
attaques edouard philippe et agnès buzyn
devant la cour de justice de la
république pour négligence coupable est
bien là la fédération cgt de la santé a
également déposé une plainte parce que
effectivement il ya eu des manquements
mais vous savez là
en ce qui concerne les épaves nous avons
également déposé un référé pour demander
à ce que dans les ehpad on puisse avoir
un dépistage systématique des résidents
et des soignants or le conseil d'état
vient de nous dégoûter au motif au motif
de la pénurie de moyens donc le conseil
d'état nous donne raison
donc seulement d'aujourd'hui c'est que
l'état arrête de tergiverser et compter
sur la charité publique réquisitionne
les entreprises organisent la production
des moyens nécessaires pour la
protection des soignants et de la
population et organise la logistique
pour une répartition de ces moyens
un contrôle des prix pour que ça soit
pas la foire d'empoigné voyez ce qu'on a
pu constater ce qu'on a pu voir y
compris sur votre antenne c'est à dire
l'état et des conseils départementaux
des conseils régionaux qui se battent au
pied d'un avion pour récupérer les
masques ont été commandés à l'étranger
pas vraiment on a l'impression d'être
dans un pays du tiers monde
je reviens sur les médecins libéraux qui
sont décédés on parle de 2,21
docteur 4000 arrêt de travail est ce que
vous êtes en lien avec certains d'entre
eux des médecins de ville dans quel état
d'esprit est ce qu'ils sont et comment
est-ce que nous la france on se situe
par rapport à nos voisins européens
c'est qu'ils lui par exemple beaucoup de
personnel soignant un mort aussi en
italie par exemple c'est une polémique
européenne selon vous écoutez j'ai une
polémique française vous savez que hier
à nos collègues médecin urgentiste à
l'hôpital lons dole lons le saunier est
décédé ils avaient été contaminés au
travail début mars et le virus a
finalement gagné après plusieurs jours
en réanimation
donc ce qui pose problème c'est que nous
avons posé la question au gouvernement
au chsct national pour connaître le
nombre de soignants touché le nombre de
soignants hospitalisés nombre de
soignants hospitalisés en réanimation et
le nombre de soignants décédé
le ministre de la santé a été incapable
de nous donner des chiffres précis et
validé voilà donc on a non seulement une
administration en l'occurrence les
agences raddad de santé un ministère de
la santé qui n'est pas capable de nous
offrir de nous donner les moyens de
protection et qui n'est même pas capable
de compter les morts c'est quand même
voyez assez rageant parce que il suffit
pas de le qualifier de héros vous savez
aujourd'hui les héros sont fatigués sont
en colère et aimerait bien qu'au-delà de
ce discours compassionnels de la part
des dirigeants
eh bien on nous écoute et on donne les
moyens de travailler aujourd'hui et
demain parce que vous savez aujourd'hui
le pic de l'épidémie est passé dans en
ile de france et dans la région grand
est
et bien heureusement pour les patients
qui ont été un peu laissé de côté les
services rouvre les consultations rouvre
des blocs opératoires ouvre mais rien
n'a changé on a l'impression que la
crise n'a été qu'une parenthèse parce
que les plans d'économies les plans de
fermetures de lits
les plans de retour à l'équipe
financiers des établissements et bien
sont toujours d'actualité et comme l'a
dit le premier ministre après avoir
limogé
on les propos malheureux le directeur
général de l'agencé de santé du grand
est eh bien les plans sont suspendus
nous demandons pas que les ponts soient
suspendus le mans veut que les plans
soient annulées annulés et qu'on puisse
de nouveau discutée et bien de l'avenir
de nos hôpitaux et où il ya et je je
termine sur mon collègue qui est décédé
le docteur éric loupiac bien c'est lui
qui se battaient pour maintenir la
deuxième équipe de smur à l'hôpital de
lons le saunier bien il est pas là pour
continuer la bataille mais on va
continuer la bataille pour lui pour son
honneur et pour que finalement on gagne
le maintien de cette deuxième équipe de
smur à lons le saunier christophe
prudhomme
il ya une autre polémique ir suite
cellule investigation de radio france et
et du poing sur 8500 respirateur
commandé en urgence qui ne serait pas
adapté à la lutte contre le coronavirus
le gouvernement qui a démenti hier votre
position par rapport à cette nouvelle
polémique mais ya pas de polémique les
respirateurs ne sont pas les
respirateurs de réanimation c'est
respirateur sont des restes respirateur
de transport je les connais bien je les
ai utilisés ce sont des respirateurs de
secours qui sont très utiles dans les
véhicules du samu pour transporter un
patient du service de réanimation
jusqu au scanner ou pour un autre examen
mais ce ne sont pas des respirateurs qui
sont adaptés pour ventiler pendant
plusieurs jours plusieurs semaines des
patients dont les poumons sont dans un
état de dégradation avancée voilà donc
il faut être clair nous n'avons plus
l'industrie en france et relais qu'ils
fabriquent des respirateurs mais qui
sont les respirateurs bas de gamme
pourquoi l'allemagne aujourd'hui à
beaucoup plus de lits de réanimation en
équipements que nous parce que ils ont
encore des usines qui fabriquent des
respirateurs de haut niveau voilà que
nous n'avons plus en france parce que
ces dernières années eh bien écoutez on
a les industriels qui vous expliquer
comment de l'industrie c'était de
continuer à travailler mais sans usines
donc c'est une question de souveraineté
nationale on sait qu emmanuel macron on
a beaucoup parlé là encore
parler de cela hier lors de sa brève
allocution la souveraineté nationale
pour pouvoir confectionner les objets
dont la france a besoin
écoutez les promesses c'est pas des
promesses dont nous avons besoin
aujourd'hui vous savez nous sommes face
à un gouvernement qui ne répond pas à ce
qu'on lui demande
quand nous demandons effectivement des
augmentations de salaires il nous
propose une prime pour solde de tout
compte
ça nous fâche ça nous fait énormément
quand nous demandons effectivement de
discuter de l'avenir de nos hôpitaux et
pour que cet avenir soit serein et bien
c'est pas simplement un allègement de
d'un tiers de la dette nous demandons
l'annulation de la dette
vous savez on aligne les milliards pour
les entreprises la dette des hôpitaux
ces 30 milliards ce que nous demandons
officiellement aujourd'hui c'est
l'annulation de la dette des hôpitaux
qui est une lettre dette illégitime
parce que l'état s'est désengagé de
l'investissement dans les hôpitaux a
obligé les hôpitaux à emprunter auprès
des banques commerciales à des taux
parfois usuraires puisqu'il ya encore
quelques années des hôpitaux avec des
emprunts dits toxiques indexés par
exemple sur le franc suisse
avec des taux d'intérêt qui frisait les
20% et bien voilà il faut que ça change
et donc ce ne sont pas simplement des
discours et les promesses et bien que
monsieur macro que monsieur macron nous
annonce qu'il annule la dette des
hôpitaux et la serre on pourra dire que
effectivement nous avons un premier
geste concret chiffré de la part du
président de la république et pas
simplement des promesses merci
christophe problème d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
médecin au samu de seine-saint-denis
porte parole de l'association des
médecins urgentistes de france et
responsable cgt